flying in shooting is definitely the
bread and butter of Ironman VR but in
addition to that you'll experience a lot
more of what it's like to be Tony and in
that way you'll return to the mansion
jump in his garage start tinkering on
your suit and you're learning more about
Tony the man behind the suit in addition
to flying around in his suit
products uder now
so one of the fun and easy aspects of
being a developer on Ironman VR is that
you kind of know what you need to
execute on if you just look at the
comics and the films and just talk to
fans of the franchise and that's why
we've built the Tony Stark garage in
Malibu the Liao's players to kind of
relax and just be Tony listen to the
radio work out but also be able to tweet
the suit and make it feel like this is
your suit that you're customizing and
improving you can customize your
bolsters and you can craft additional
weapons for the auxilary slots you also
have argument slots that you can craft
equipment for for upgrading your HUD
capabilities your thrusters or tweak the
way the suit uses ammo I told you your
old weapons would be the death of you
Stark when they put on that helmet and
the HUD boots up and they grab those
controllers and they pull the triggers
and you start flying around that they
feel like Iron Man but they feel like
Tony Stark when they're going back to
the garage tinkering on their suit
interacting with pepper as of today
Stark Industries no longer makes or
sells weapons of any kind I want to tell
a story that when players put down the
controllers and walk away from the game
they continue to think about a story
that's compelling engaging and explores
the depth of Tony Stark as a character
aha time for the heroes
PlayStation